this is a production of cornell
university
so hi everyone my talk today will
provide an overview
of my proposed research on studying
bacterial adhesive mechanisms and how
they may influence soil aggregate
stability
and the resulting effects on soil
organic carbon
persistence so to start we need to
understand how solar organic carbon
persists
in aggregates in the soil continuum
model we understand that organic carbon
turnover time
increases with increased adsorption of
organic matter
to mineral surfaces and the formation of
aggregates
focusing on the structure of an
aggregate we see
organic matter such as exudates
necromats
and enzymes being protected by minerals
that act as a physical barrier
stopping organic matter from being
immediately decomposed or turned over
some of this organic matter may also
facilitate aggregation
via organomineral interactions and
organo-organic interactions
microorganisms have also been shown to
contribute to aggregate stability
specifically
fungi which produce myostillon networks
that can enmesh
minerals and catalyze the adhesion of
other organic carbon
onto the aggregate but what about
bacteria
do bacteria bacterial cells produce
organic adhesives
that contribute to aggregate stability
and if so would we see a change in soil
organic carbon
mineralization rates depending on if the
bacterial adhesive
is present or not to try and answer
these questions i decided to
investigate bacterial organic adhesives
and found
that the initial irreversible step of
adhesion for many
bacteria is through the production of a
multi-layered polysaccharide complex
called the holdfast
the model organism commonly used to
study the bacterial holdfast
is colobactor consentus within the last
two years in particular
large steps have been made to
characterize the hold fast protein
complex its physiology and adhesion
strength
however the mechanism of adhesion of the
hold fast
is still unknown meaning that we do not
know if the adhesion mechanism
occurs through chemical reactions at the
holdfast
mineral interface or if the adhesion
mechanism occurs through
physical mechanisms at the holdfast
mineral
interface so an example of a chemical
adhesion mechanism is like epoxy
and the mechanical adhesion mechanism
example is like velcro
so to answer these questions i
decided to divide my research into three
chapters
where the first chapter is about
answering the question of what is the
mechanism that allows the bacterial hold
face to adhere to mineral substrates
the second chapter does the presence of
the bacterial holdfast
influence solar aggregate stability how
is this reflected in the persistence of
non-hold fast solar organic carbon
and then the third chapter going into
the space side of my research
is does gravity trigger the production
of bacterial holdfast and therefore the
creation and stabilization
of aggregates so to get started with
chapter
one uh in which the goal was to
understand the mechano
chemistry at the hold fast mineral
interface and the resulting adhesive
strength from the interaction
so there are two objectives i have with
this chapter
of course determined the
mechanochemistry of
the colibacter consensus holdfast at the
mineral interface
um and the hypothesis i have for this
is that the interfaces will be rich in
nitrogen phosphorous and oxidized carbon
specifically because the hold fast we
we've seen through previous studies
that the hold fast is made of things
like dna
and peptides and with the presence of
dna and peptides the adhesive strength
has been shown
to increase so we might see interfaces
that are rich in these kinds of elements
and then objective two uh to determine
the chemical
and or surface morphology mechanism of
the adhesion
uh between the colored background is
hold fast and the mineral substrate
uh so understanding if the mechanism is
primarily driven by
chemical interactions or if it's
driven by mechanical stabilization uh i
believe that it's gonna be more likely
to be a chemical
interaction that we see so
to meet this first objective of
understanding the
elemental chemical signatures at the
holdfast
mineral interface i propose using
scanning transmission electron
microscopy analysis
in which with this uh microscopy
technique we can really get down
to that interface between the
microorganism
hold fast and the mineral and use
uh eels edx pretty much these
uh techniques that allow us to read the
chemistry on the surface
and understand what's potentially
happening here on an elemental level
level
as well as what the potential chemical
bonds are that are
happening between the hold fast and the
mineral interface
and so to do this pretty much uh we take
the collobactor consensus hold fast
separated from the cell there is a
uh a technique that we can use to create
a shedding uh a shedding
uh phenotype for the cell where the hold
fast can be separated
from the cell the bacterial cell and
then we take the hold fast
and incubate it onto an stm grid
interacting with a mica sheet
and then go for the analysis of using
stem scanning transmission electron
microscopy at
cornell's ccmr facility
and then with the second objective which
is hold fast adhesion mechanism
understanding uh if it's a chemical or a
physical
mechanism at the at the interface
we can perform dynamic adhesion for
spectroscopy
experiment using atomic force microscopy
and
pretty much with this kind of experiment
your result will look
something like this where the
atomic force microscopy probe uh
has the holdfast material attached to it
and then you go through a tapping or a
probing
experiment where it sticks the hold fast
onto the substrate and then
pulls up and it measures the work of
adhesion
with being stuck down and being pulled
up and so we'll
get diagrams like this from the
experiment
and so to test whether it's a chemical
or physical mechanism
again we take the colibacter consensus
holdfast by itself
we incubate it onto
the probe tip of the
atomic force microscopy instrument and
then
we do a chemical adhesion test where we
have something like a mica surface
with a different surface charge to see
if there is a difference
in the the force work of adhesion
data that we get oh and then with the
mechanical adhesion test understanding
if it's due to surface morphology
we can take something like a quartz
surface and have a smooth surface
versus a jagged rough surface to see
if that has an effect on
the force uh uh that we're measuring
for the uh hold fast adhesion
so that was chapter one going into
chapter two uh
the goal is to understand how the
presence of bacterial hold fast
might prevent stability and the
persistence of non-hold faster
organic carbon so the
objective here is to really link the
occurrence and abundance of the hold
fast
with aggregate stability and see if this
actually confers persistence to other
solar organic carbon
so the hypothesis that i've come up with
here is that the increased presence of
collobacter placentas hold fast in the
aggregate will increase overall
aggregate stability
and that souls in which calibrator
consensus hold fast is present will have
decreased
organic carbon mineralization of
non-hold fast soil organic carbon
so to answer these questions
uh pretty much uh i'll be needing i'll
be using two sand columns
uh where one of them will be incubated
with
the wild type of colobactor consentus
with the normal production of whole fast
material and then the other
uh sterile sand column will have
a deficient strain where this colobactor
crescentus doesn't
produce the holdfast or is deficient in
producing the hold fast material
and then to answer the question of does
the presence of whole fast
material influence influence aggregate
stability
we can do aggregate fractionation to
measure aggregate stability
and then to measure to answer the
question of
does the presence of hold fast material
influence non-holdfast
solar organic carbon mineralization
in these tubes i'll also have sodalime
so that we can do
an absorption of uh 13c labeled co2
and get the percent 13c as well as the
total carbon
uh within these tubes to see the
mineralization process
and then using nanosims which is a
device that allows you to do elemental
and isotopic
composition analysis between
organic materials and other solids
and with this you would get something
like this
so within these uh tubes i would also
have
13 c labeled cellulose
and 15 and labeled chitin to
differentiate between
the organic matter that we introduce
and differentiate between the bacterial
cells
themselves and in nanosims we are able
to
analyze these aggregate structures
and differentiate between uh
what's remaining of the 13c labeled
organic matter and what is le
and where the cells are in and on
the aggregate structure
and then with chapter three uh
which is going into the space side of
the research
i want to understand if gravity is a
part
of microbials or aggregation mechanisms
on earth
and some of you may be asking why why do
we
want or should do
experiments in space um
and a common uh
reason why astrobiology is a thing
and uh taking plants onto the
international space station is a thing
is because gravity is known to have this
masking effect
so if you imagine the caulobacter
crescentus cell
and it has it's at its holdfast holding
it onto a mineral
keeping it in place uh you
you can imagine that you have this huge
force vector of gravity
pulling it down and we kind of make this
assumption
that most likely one of the reasons why
this hold holdfast material was
naturally selected for
is because of the evolution of the
colobactor consentus
in earth's gravity earth's gravity is
trying to pull the cell down and if the
cell did not have this organic adhesive
it would just be washed through the soil
column and wouldn't be able to
adhere near uh
areas of interest in the in the soil so
we kind of make this assumption that
this organism evolved due to this
force vector of gravity but when we take
organisms outside of earth's gravity
and into an environment where you can
isolate that
sometimes it can be surprising that
we actually don't see a change in
the fundamental mechanisms or biological
processes within an organism
meaning that if you compare the sample
you have
in earth gravity to the sample that you
have on the international space station
nothing changed which means that
this mechanism this biological process
that
you are studying is actually inherent
to the organism meaning that if you had
the organism on
mars or on the moon or on earth or on
the international space station the same
process would stay the same it's not
gravity dependent so
i wanted to ask the same question for
uh natural earth soils specifically the
questions of
is the production of whole fast by
bacteria inherent
to bacteria meaning it's independent of
gravity
or is the production of holdfast
dependent on the presence of earth
gravity
meaning that as when we look at it
on the international space station the
production of the hold fast is going to
change because
its production is dependent on having
that
gravitational force so the two
objectives
that i have here for this chapter is of
course understand the effect of gravity
on fungal myosin
and bacterial hold fast production in
soil
um and with this one we believe that
fungal myosin production
will decrease in the absence of gravity
specifically
more likely due to the
abiotic factor of in a microgravity
environment your soil
matrix may be floating
with the soil particles going everywhere
and bact
uh fungi milestone really rely on being
able to spread
across uh the soil matrix so we might
see an actual decrease
in milestone production as well as a
decrease in the fungal population
in the absence of gravity and then with
bacteria we also think that
potentially we'll see a
decrease in hold fast production in the
absence of gravity and this
we the reasoning that we have for that
is that
because gravity is no longer pulling
down
uh on the bacteria uh and threatening
the bacteria uh being
washed out of the soil column away from
nutrient sources
that the bacteria may still adhere to
minerals but doesn't have to produce as
much
uh hold fast to work against
such a big force vector
so we believe that bacteria will produce
less hold fast in this case
um and then objective two determine
alterations and solar aggregate
stability in the absence of gravity
uh we believe that aggregate stability
will decrease due to the
associated decrease in microbial organic
adhesive production as we've saw
with our hypotheses in objective one and
that more
micro aggregates will be present
compared to macro aggregates for this
very same reason
that um for macro aggregates to form
uh having the microbial organic adhesive
production
uh to hold together uh these aggregates
is
is very important and so the decreased
production of this
will lead to those macro aggregates
either not forming or being highly
unstable
and so with this experiment it's a
30-day incubation experiment
that's currently up on the international
space station it launched
back in earlier this month out of
wallops flight facility in virginia
so i was there for that and that was
exciting and this
experiment consists of three different
soil types
you have the soil from ithaca you have a
soil from berlin germany
and then you have a biochar potting
media from bio
365 here in ithaca new york
and the uh the treatments for
the soils are the same across the soils
uh
you have 12 tubes per soil
and these are divided into six tubes
that have restricted movement and six
tubes that have loose movement
and this is pretty much studying the
abiotic
element of having
increased space between the soil
particles like i was saying before
with loose movement allowing the soil to
just float in the microgravity
environment
does that have an effect on the
microbial population dynamics as well as
the production of these organic
adhesives
versus the tubes that have restricted
movement where they've been
stoppered into place still allowing for
gas and water exchange but stoppered
into place
so that the soil minerals are actually
closer together and kept closer together
and then
those are subdivided into having sixty
percent waterhole
holding capacity versus thirty percent
water holding capacity
which thirty percent water holding
capacity is closer
to drought conditions while 60 is more
optimal
and so this is studying more of the
biotic
factor of our samples understanding
uh how the microorganisms are reacting
in this kind of environment and so
to meet the objectives of the experiment
the iss samples are going to be compared
to earth-based control samples
and pretty much we're doing a lot of the
same things that
i proposed in the last two chapters
we're looking at carbon and
decomposition dynamics
looking at the total carbon of the
samples through the atmosphere of the
tube
any change in mass of the organic matter
that we have in
the soil samples looking at aggregate
presence and stability
so using a particle counter to see if we
have
any aggregates that formed uh
larger than the size that we sieve the
soil to
as well as pulling out some of those
potential aggregates and doing aggregate
fractionation to see
how stable they are and then using
scanning transmission electron
microscopy to really analyze the hold
fast
uh mineral interface and then we have a
collaborator that's
uh specifically working on the
microbiome characterization
of the experiment and so the
implications here
of doing this work overall is that
being able to understand the bacterial
adhesive mechanism of colobacto
consensus could provide insight into
other bacterial adhesive mechanisms that
haven't been fully characterized
it will also help us understand how to
better manage
the soil microbiome in different systems
here on earth
understanding that if gravity really
isn't part of the mechanism driving the
production
of uh hold fast and organic adhesive
production
what's really driving that mechanism and
how can we implement management
practices
to better
help the creation of organic adhesive if
we see that it actually helps
with soil organic carbon sequestration
and then of course microbial development
in different gravity environments uh
understanding this is more the planetary
science side of things uh when we go to
mars
when we're on the moon uh do we go with
an
understanding that it's possible that
microorganisms can survive and produce
these organic adhesives
uh on other planets in differing gravity
environments
and then of course furthermore in the
industry
adhesives are
a growing field of research and
production especially producing
adhesives
that come from organic natural systems
and so there actually has been a lot of
interest in
seeing how we can pull calibractor
consensus holdfast
out of the environment and actually
implement it in industry as
an adhesive and then of course
saying thank you to the contributors of
my research my phd committee
dr lehmann dr martinez and dr hay
research collaborators uh dr rolly
wilhelm who's a post-doc here in the
buckley lab
he's definitely helped a lot with
helping me understand
uh the hold fast and colobactor
consensus
and then dr matthias relic who's
partnering with us on
the international space station
experiment
and then of course funding uh from my
nsf graduate research program fellowship
a fellowship i
have through norfolk institute and
funding we got from the zwillenberg
teach
stifton foundation in germany and then
our industry collaborators and sponsors
such as deep space ecology rhodium
scientific bio365
cases iss national lab and
nasa so that's my presentation
thank you for listening great so morgan
thank you that was a great presentation
and really really interesting work
um and it's nice to start seeing it all
coming
to fruition on your space station
experiment with the tubes where you've
got the soil i'm curious and i may have
missed it you may have said it
um what is the pressure temperature and
most importantly
the composition of the atmosphere that
the soil is being exposed to there
yeah so it's at uh so
because these are natural natural earth
samples
uh and the biochar sample um
with microorganisms and living in them
we had to double contain them
uh so they're in their tubes
they're sealed with and then sealed
within two
heat sealed baggies um because
the iss is very much
about keeping everything as sterile as
possible yeah absolutely
it was a journey to get these samples up
there uh
but uh so within the tubes themselves
they have
the atmosphere composition that they
pretty much had here on earth when we
sealed them
um temperature wise uh they are at
the same ambient temperature of the
international space station
uh which is about room temperature
pretty much
um and i i did forget to mention that we
do have
chemical uh temperature sensors that are
uh right next to our samples so we will
be getting a temperature data
uh so that we can better control our
ground
samples to match the same
temperature and atmospheric dynamics as
they have on the international space
station
terrific so those tubes are fitted with
septa then so you can do your post
analysis gas sampling thank you so much
morgan
thank you
any other questions from morgan
yeah let's get again i had one
i just want to know how you how unique
is this i mean is this the first soil
that's going to the space station i
i'm quite ignorant on this topic um i
mean how yeah
yeah so it is the first time natural
earth soil has been
sent into space um which is super
exciting and a big win for
soil science um i think
pretty much the what they do with plant
experiments on the international space
station a lot of it is hydroponics
uh technology as well as if they do
have a substrate it's an engineered
substrate like
uh to use like seed pillows things like
that
but never an actual earth soil um so
if you see mention
of like i know that the chinese they
sent an experiment to the moon where
they were growing plants seeds in
soil we contacted them just to verify
uh what what they were actually growing
in and they were using
a engineered vermiculite that they
had put additives to so uh
yes our samples are the first actual
natural earth soils to go in space so
so we have to get a new soil order for
this or something we'll see
yeah yeah um kirsten she actually made
this pun
she uh she said that we've
we're bringing the soil profile to new
horizons
so the horizon of space we now have the
s horizon
oh now that is good above the l horizon
is the s horizon very good okay thank
you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu